- You need to believe in
yourself, despite what everybody
you love and trust tells you.
Ben and I had a joint back
account, and we'd go to,
if you made money acting,
it went into the account,
and the account was only to be used if,
if you were going to New
York for an audition.
But I mean, we really
wrote "Good Will Hunting,"
out of necessity, I mean,
we just needed a job.
You don't get anywhere being,
you know, genuflecting,
to, you know, somebody.
- He's an American actor, film
producer, and screenwriter.
He's ranked by Forbes
magazine, as one of the
most bankable Hollywood
stars, and is among
the highest grossing actors of all time.
He's received numerous
accolades, including
one Academy Award, from four nominations.
He's Matt Damon, and here's my take on his
Top 10 Rules for Success.
Rule number one is our personal
favorite, and make sure
to stick around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
(bullseye sound effect)
- When I was younger everybody
told me not to be an actor.
To this day, I say that to
people, who come up to me,
and say, I'm thinking of going
into acting, what do you think?
I say, absolutely not, it's
a terrible idea, don't do it.
Because, that's what everyone said to me.
And, I think if you're going
to make it in this business,
that is so full of rejection and hardship,
you need to believe in
yourself, despite what everybody
you love and trust tells you.
And, it's a very personal journey.
And so, so that was
really helpful, I think,
you know, the advice to
stay away from this career
was really helpful in my
own understanding, that,
it was that important that I pursue it.
You know, and the first
job I got was a real job,
besides commercials and things like that.
Local radio commercials and things
that kind of gave us the money.
Ben and I had a joint bank
account, and we'd go to,
and if you made money acting,
it went into the account,
and the account was only to be used
if you were going to New
York for an audition,
or if we took $10 out to
like, play video games.
(laughs)
And, I got a line in the
movie "Mystic Pizza."
And the line was, "Mom, do
you want my green stuff?"
And literally, but it was a scene that was
a big dinner table scene, Julia Roberts...
- Yeah.
- It was like, a big movie for her, and,
it was this whole dinner table scene, and,
so it took us three nights to shoot,
down in Mystic, Connecticut,
and I was a minor,
so my mother had to come
with me, and, you know,
we shot from 5 to 5 every night, and,
I just remember being,
so in love with the process
of film, I just, I was like,
this is, the greatest,
it was the best time
I'd ever had in my life,
and it was, you know,
I was like, this is amazing, I want this
to never ever ever stop.
Like, I loved it.
- But I mean, we really
wrote "Good Will Hunting,"
out of necessity, I mean,
we just needed a job.
And, you know, as you all know,
they don't really give those out here.
(laughs)
So, it was just, you know,
two guys who were eager and
young, and had a lot of energy,
and a lot of creative energy, and,
that's a big, it was
always a big problem with,
L.A. and New York, was you'd,
you know, you'd meet these
other actors, and they'd,
and it's like,
you're raring to go, and there's nowhere
to put that energy, and so, you know,
it can get put in horrible
places, it can get put in,
you know, drugs and all that, you know.
Or you can try to somehow channel it
into something that feels productive.
And even if it doesn't,
nothing comes of it,
it's still productive, in the
sense that you're working.
Even if you're getting together in groups
and doing scenes, or taking classes, or,
trying to cobble together a screenplay,
the energy's going somewhere.
- You have never seemed,
shackled, Matt, over your career
by the fear of needing
to maintain some sort
of particular image,
you've always been happy
to speak out on issues that
you are concerned about,
or to do whatever
projects take your fancy.
How have you managed to slip those chains?
- I just never thought
that you could micro-manage
an image, you know, I
just didn't, you know.
And the things I've
spoken about, I've just,
you know, are things that I believe, and,
it doesn't mean that I'm
right, it just, you know,
and I'm happy to learn and
evolve in my thinking, and,
but, if I'm saying something,
it's because it's what
I'm genuinely feeling, and,
you know, and that's,
I don't think I've taken
too many hits for that.
My high school acting
teacher, Gerry Speca,
who had a huge influence on me
and Ben and Casey,
five words, he said,
just do your work, kid.
And he repeated that so many times to me,
just do your work, kid,
and that is kind of,
what I can always retreat to, you know,
that's my touchstone if,
you know, when in doubt,
just focus on my work,
you know, if everything on
the movie's going wrong,
all right, you know, I'll make
sure that my work is tight,
and, go from there and it's
a great place to base from,
and it's a good foundation.
I looked at the odds, you know,
like how am I even going to
break into this business?
Right, all the good parts, you know,
as an unknown actor, to get a great role,
you know, every other
actor has to pass on it.
Right.
Every other actor has to pass on it.
And then it gets opened
up to you, and thousands
of other people like you, right.
(audience laughs)
And you all go.
And, you know, there are a
few parts, like I was looking
at the, you know, a big part when I was,
younger, was "Primal
Fear," remember that movie,
with Richard Gere, and
Edward Norton got the part.
- [Interviewer] After everyone passed.
- Yeah, I mean, so that part became open,
every young actor knew it.
I mean, we, I paid, with
money I did not have,
to take dialect lessons, you know,
hired a dialect coach,
cause the kid was, you know,
his alter ego was from
Kentucky, and he was
from somewhere else, and I
had never been to Kentucky,
and so, you know,
we knew that that was it.
You know that was going
to launch somebody.
There just weren't
opportunities, you know.
And so, "Courage Under
Fire," was one of those roles
that was small, it was really only,
it was two scenes, right, I
had two scenes with Denzel.
And then the rest of it
was, I'm the medic, and I'm,
you know,
you know, Tim Guinee, an actor who I love,
who's in "Promised Land," actually,
is like, bleeding out on my
lap for, so for six weeks,
we're in El Paso, and he's
like, moaning, and I'm just
sitting there, and I'm like,
I don't think the camera's on us, man.
(audience laughs)
But, you know, so it was
a really thankless job,
for both of us.
(audience laughs)
Except for, those two scenes
that I had with Denzel.
So I had two days of work on
that movie, and so I went,
well what do I do, you know, it's,
it's told in flashback, so
let me see, how can I change,
myself, what can I do?
The guy's supposed to become
a heroin addict, okay.
Well, so what do I do to make that
seem like it happened,
and the only thing I could
come up with, was, to lose
as much weight as I could.
And then put it back on as fast as I could
to go do the flashback stuff.
And so that's what I did.
- I heard that wasn't
good for you health, like,
your doctor was surprised.
- No it was terrible.
It you know, it was bad
because I didn't, you know,
I asked them for a nutritionist,
which was probably $1500 or $2500.
And they said no, and you know,
I don't think they,
in their defense, I don't
think they really knew
what I was going to do.
You know, and they probably
had requests like this
all the time, and they think
they're vanity requests.
But it was a serious request, and,
and they turned it down, and so,
I went to, we had a friend, we knew a guy.
(audience laughs)
Who was also a, he was Austrian.
I mean, funnily enough,
he was Austrian, and he
was trying to be an actor.
But he literally, because he was Austrian,
he had Arnold's accent.
And he was a former body builder.
So, he was really aiming at
a small bullseye, you know.
(audience laughs)
Cause his spot was
really taken by somebody.
(audience laughs)
But he, he put me on his
program that he would do
for body building shows.
But they would do that
program three weeks out.
You know, they would do this really,
kind of reckless thing, when they're,
you know, and so those guys
walk onstage, and, like,
you could push, they look
strong, but you could
knock 'em over, they're really,
suffering at that point,
to kind of leech every
bit of everything out,
so that the veins and the muscles pop out.
So, I did it for like, three
and a half or four months.
Which was just, too
much, you know, too much.
And it, but, at the same time,
you know, it worked.
It worked, and you know,
when I got "The Rainmaker,"
a year or so later, Coppola said
that he'd seen "Courage Under Fire."
And that that made a big difference.
And funnily enough, it was
Edward Norton and I, who were
going against each other again for that.
And "Courage Under Fire"
pushed me over the edge.
And when I met Spielberg later,
and he looked at me, and he said,
what, you know,
and I'd put myself on tape
for "Saving Private Ryan."
I never heard anything,
I don't think the tape ever got to him.
The casting director maybe
looked at it and chucked it,
you know, and,
so I thought he'd you know, seen it.
And he said, what do I know you from?
And I said I put myself
on tape for your movie.
He goes, no, I didn't see any tape.
He goes what movies have you been in?
I said I was in a movie
called "Courage Under Fire."
He goes,
(snaps fingers)
You know, I turned to my
wife when I saw that movie,
and said, "that's the exact
guy I want for Private Ryan,
"I just wish he wasn't so skinny."
(audience laughs)
So.
- I feel like I read a interview,
at the time, that said,
like, you couldn't even
kiss your girlfriend,
cause you could taste
potato chips on her lips?
- The oil from them, yeah.
No, I mean, it went,
people who have those disorders,
I got it.
I totally understood it.
Like if you want to
be, I just told myself,
I can't allow anything,
there's no, no compromising.
None, like, because the
second you open that door,
you know, it's a slippery slope.
And I just, I wanted to
look back on it, and go,
I did absolutely everything I could.
- [Interviewer] This
relationship between you and Ben.
It's a kind of, he busts
you, and you bust him back.
There's a little bit
of that, a lot of that.
It's the nature of two
guys growing up together.
- Yeah.
- [Robin Williams] Yeah.
- But there's also this thing
that we're talking about,
we just saw in this scene,
is that there, is that
who the two of you are in
terms of, to each other?
- Oh yeah, I mean, we...
- [Interviewer] Kind of
grown up together in Boston,
part of Cambridge and all that.
- Sure, yeah, growing up together,
best friends all our lives, we don't have,
I wouldn't say we have moments
that are that, kind of,
dramatic, where we're like,
listen, man, you know.
But, you know, I'd lay down
in traffic for the guy.
I mean, you know, he's my
best pal, you know, I mean.
You know, I'd pretty
much do anything for him.
So, yeah, I mean, it's a,
you know, it's a great
friendship, you know.
I can't imagine a better way to,
make a movie, and do something
I love to do that much,
than with Ben, and to have
this go the way it did,
and have, this happen, you know.
And Tom Hanks said something
to me, when we were doing
"Saving Private Ryan,"
that always stuck with me,
which was, I was asking
him about, a movie he did
with Jackie Gleason, and I said,
what was it like to work
with Jackie Gleason?
And he thought about it for a
second and he said, you know,
I made a decision to not be nervous.
And I went, what?
And he goes, I knew everyone
was so nervous around him.
And I just said, you know what,
I'm not going to be nervous
around him, and he,
and once he realized I
was treating him like,
you know, a fellow human being,
we really had this great
working relationship,
and it was really good advice, you know.
- And so you try to do that yourself?
- I was trying to do it
with Tom Hanks at the time.
(laughs)
And, yeah, you don't get anywhere being,
you know, genuflecting,
to, you know somebody.
- And I know a lot has been
said and written about the
experience of "Good Will Hunting," but,
could you ever have imagined that
it would have such an effect on people?
You touched so many lives with that movie,
it was amazing.
- It's really great, looking back, I mean,
it,
Ben and I had this pact that,
we just wanted the movie,
that, no matter what,
we wanted to love it.
And, even if nobody saw it,
and it was a great early
lesson, that, you know,
because even if the movie
hadn't been successful,
we still would have loved it, and,
and it would have meant as much to us.
So I've, you know, not to
be a horrible name dropper,
but, Clint Eastwood said
to me, a couple years ago,
I was asking him about, just stuff,
we were sitting on the set
while they were setting up
a shot, and, he said, you know,
people talk about my movies, and they say,
well, this one's a masterpiece,
or, that one's no good,
and he goes, I love all of them.
And I know exactly why
I made each one of them.
And I wouldn't do anything differently,
if I had to do it again.
- [Interviewer] Al Pacino said
the secret to success, is...
- But what does he know?
- Yeah, exactly, well.
I was going to say, he
said the secret to success
is learning his lines,
or learning your lines.
What do you reckon the
secret to success is?
- I never heard that, that's great.
That is definitely one of
the secrets to success.
Yeah, having something to say,
and knowing what it is, yeah.
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I made this video because
MrPlaythroughs101 asked me to,
so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave
it in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of the Top 10 rules here,
had the biggest impact on you and why,
what change you're going
to make, what realization
did you come to after watching this video,
leave it in the comments, and
I will join in the discussion.
Finally, want to give a
quick shout out to Xavier,
from scentlion.com, thank you
so much for buying my book,
it really means a lot to me.
Those of you watching, you
want a chance at a shout out
in a future video, make sure to,
pick up a copy of the book,
and email in your receipt,
so we can keep track.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe, or
whatever your one word is.
And I'll see you soon.
(bullseye sound effect)
(background crowd noise)
(girls laugh)
- [Chuckie] Oh, hello.
- [Skylar] Oh, hello.
- [Chuckie] Hi, how are ya?
- [Skylar] Fine.
- [Chuckie] So do you ladies...
- [Skylar] Come here often?
- [Chuckie] Do I come here?
I come here a bit, I'm here, eh,
you know, from time to time.
Do you go to school here?
- [Lydia] Yep.
- Yeah.
That's it, cause I think
I had a class with you.
- Oh yeah, what class?
- History.
- [Skylar] Maybe.
- [Chuckie] Yes, I think
that's what it was.
You don't necessarily, might
not remember me, you know,
I like it here, it doesn't
mean cause I go here
I'm a genius, I am very smart.
- [Clark] Hey.
- Hey, how's it going, how are ya?
- [Clark] Good, how you doing?
What class did you say that was?
- History.
- Yeah, just "History?"
It must have been a
survey course, then, huh?
- Yeah, it was, it was surveys.
You should check it
out, it's a good course.
It's a pretty good class.
- [Clark] How'd you like that course?
- You know, frankly,
I found the class, you know, rather,
elementary.
- Elementary.
You know, I don't doubt that it was.
- [Chuckie] Yeah.
- I eh, I remember that class, it was, um,
it was just between recess, and lunch.
- Clark, why don't you go away?
- [Clark] Why don't you relax?
- [Skylar] Why don't you just go away?
- I'm just having fun with
my new friend, that's all.
- You going to have a problem?
- No no no no, there's no problem here.
I was just hoping you
might give me some insight
into the evolution of the market economy
in the southern colonies.
My contention is that, prior
to the Revolutionary War,
the economic modalities, especially,
in the southern colonies, could
most aptly be characterized
as, agrarian...
- Let me tell you something,
all right, hang on a second.
- [Will] You're a first-year grad student,
you just got finished
reading some waxy historian,
Pete Garrison, probably.
You're going to be convinced
of that til next month
when you get to James
Lemon, then you're going to
be talking about how the
economies of Virginia
and Pennsylvania were
entrepreneurial and capitalist
way back in 1740.
That's going to last until next
year, you're going to be in here
regurgitating Gordon Wood,
talking about, you know,
the pre-Revolutionary utopia
and the capital forming
effects of military mobilization.
- As a matter of fact, I
won't, because Wood drastically
underestimates the impact of social...
- Wood drastically, Wood
drastically underestimates
the impact of social
distinctions predicated
upon wealth, especially inherited wealth?
You got that from Vickers.
"Work in Essex County," page 98, right?
Yeah, I read that, too.
Were you going to plagiarize
the whole thing for us,
or you have any thoughts
of your own on this matter?
Or is that your thing,
you just come into a bar,
you read some obscure
passage, and then pretend
you pawn it off as your own,
as your own idea, just
to impress some girls?
Embarrass my friend?
See, the sad thing about a
guy like you, is in 50 years,
you're going to start doing
some thinking on your own,
and you're going to come up
with the fact that there are
two certainties in life.
One, don't do that.
And two, you dropped 150
grand on a fucking education
you could have got for a
dollar fifty in lay charges
at the public library.
(onlooker laughs)
- Yeah, but I will have a degree.
You'll be serving my kids
fries at a drive-through
on our way to a skiing trip.
(laughs)
- Yeah, maybe.
But at least I won't be unoriginal.
But I mean, if you have
a problem like that,
I mean, we could just step
outside, we could figure it out.
- Nah man, there's no problem.
It's cool.
- [Will] It's cool?
- Yeah.
- Cool.
- [Bearded Man] You're
fucking damn right it's cool.
- [Chuckie] How you like me now?
(onlooker laughs)
- [Morgan] My boy's wicked smart.
(mellow guitar music)
(raps on window)
- [Will] Do you like apples?
- [Clark] Yeah.
- [Will] Yeah?
(slaps window)
Well I got her number.
How you like them apples?
(Bearded Man laughs)
(folksy music plays)